any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this pandemic
podcast episode of into the impossible a
production of the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination at the university
of california san diego where we are
still sheltering in place and today we
have a wonderful new author who has
published a fantastic new book which is
generating tons and tons of buzz and
virality as is the fitting of such a
wonderful work and it's Sara fryer in
Sara's a technology reporter for
Bloomberg News who are award-winning
features and breaking stories have
earned her a reputation as an expert on
how Facebook Instagram snapchat and
Twitter make business decisions that
affect their futures and our society
fire is a frequent contributor to
Bloomberg Businessweek and Bloomberg
Television she lives in San Francisco
are you still are you sheltering they're
currently somewhere yeah okay great it's
good to see us our friends and in
Northern California are doing well and
it's really a treat to have you on on
the into the impossible podcast so thank
you so much for having me yeah it's
really a pleasure so I your book is
really fascinating because it really
reveals a lot of insights into how
technology and and science and the type
of science that myself and my colleagues
work on is really becoming you know
molded melded to things that are
normally associating a popular culture
influencer celebrities and things like
that and throughout the reading of your
fascinating book and I read it I
listened to it you know I met it ate it
on it and it's really phenomenal
everyone should get all three different
copies all three different versions and
read them all listen to them all
simultaneously but what really spoke to
me is the kind of lessons that can teach
us as a society about about both these
these huge endeavors that are
influencing our lives in ways that we
could have scarcely predicted a few
years ago and so today I want to talk
with you a little bit about the insight
that you cleaned and help the reader
glean about these huge tectonic societal
shifts and why they matter to us and and
what might be coming next so it's really
a treat to have you here
I want to start with a blurb or a review
that just I came across in the Wall
Street Journal over the weekend and the
author writes that no filter offers an
engaging account of how tech founders
ideals inevitably have to be squared
with making profits Instagram experience
usually feels like it's about more than
the company just the company's bottom
line over the past few months of
pandemic provoked lock downs many users
have been trapped at home the
influencers the normal people the
celebrities Instagram has stood out as
one of the platform's many of us relied
on to document and connect each day
despite being physically apart so I want
to ask you first how is how is Instagram
affected you I mean obviously you wrote
the book over the last year or two how
is it affecting you as we speak during
this you know this this pandemic that
we're all suffering from it's so
interesting right now to think about
Instagram because it it has as I
described in my book it has become this
place where we we go out in the world
and we share what we're doing and we use
it as this tool to present ourselves as
interesting fulfilled people full of
travel adventures and great dining and
cocktails and friends and all these
things that we we talk about on
Instagram and build our lives around
this visual aesthetic now we're all home
and we're using Instagram in a very
different manner we're using it for a
live video we're using it for messaging
we're using it to to tune into cooking
tutorials and workout tutorials live
concerts and and so suddenly this this
tool that has become sort of
performative in our society has become
something more for human connection
which has been a nice transition of
course there is a dark side right now in
kovin as well as a lot of a lot of
faulty information about health care is
is transmitted on Instagram from these
influencers but for the most part what
I've seen is a lot of people trying to
have this moment of solidarity but I
think that will change as as cities open
up more will probably see more of the
the foam oh that we've come to know and
and probably hate from Instagram the
idea that some people will be willing to
go out and experience the world the way
they did before and other people will
still be a few scared to do so mmm okay
yeah that's really fascinating and one
thing you know I look at well first of
all I want to talk a little bit about
the book itself and the physical book
especially being this physically distant
but you know socially connected I mean
it's physical you know social distancing
it's really put the social media and
social distancing and I think that's
really a fascinating development some
people have said things like I couldn't
have survived the pandemic without
Instagram also things like Netflix
obviously things like that but it's
become so integral this thing that
didn't exist like somebody said I wish I
wish you know I'm so glad that the
pandemic didn't happen thirty years ago
because we didn't have Netflix or yeah
we didn't even have the internet and you
and I were yeah yeah current usage of
Instagram and Facebook is upwards and
beyond anything they've ever seen on a
constant basis like right now we are
using Instagram more than we do during
for example the ball dropping on New
Year's Eve Wow
turning the night around the world
that's when people tend to log in and
say Happy New Year and post their videos
of fireworks right now we're doing that
constantly because we're home then we're
bored and we crave this social
connection that we can get from a more
visual medium like Instagram yeah you
and I were chatting just before we
started recording about zoom and how you
know unfortunately for your book I mean
one of the treats of an author is to go
on a book tour and I know that you'll
get that chance to do that some someday
and and they'll be so exciting for you
and you've earned it certainly by the
production of this lovely book but but
zoom has made it really possible for us
to do these podcasts and to do these
interviews yeah I don't think I would
have maybe gotten access to you if there
wasn't if there wasn't you know this
unfortunately this this this really
tragic event occurring in society at
large and and yet you know we somehow
may do without Instagram and zoom and
things like that even you know a couple
years ago their popularity is just just
taken
incredibly virally is as everyone now is
familiar with how that term got its name
I want to talk just about the book I
always say
I always ignore the advice to not judge
books by their covers and so I judge
every book by their cover and and your
book is a particularly kind of
interesting cover and it's a sort of a
double entendre I think in the title as
I as I would expect our French listeners
to say can you walk us through the cover
what went into it the publisher picked
the you know title did you pick it how
did it come to be this title I know you
work on stories for Bloomberg that led
to this I believe to led to the writing
in this book but how did the actual
cover the design the elements the colors
etcetera how do they come to be well it
happened to have the book right here yes
very nice people can take a look so so
basically I I learned from the founders
of Instagram that they really
appreciated simplicity and when they
were building Instagram they wanted to
strip it down to its most basic
components photography and do that one
thing very well and so I thought that if
I was going to do a book that adhered to
the Instagram aesthetic and gave that
sense of Instagram it would need to have
a lot of simplicity to it so that's why
we have just the the basic letters the
colors the colors that are the same some
gradient that you see in the Instagram
in the Instagram logo and the gradient
is actually a reference to the filters
that the veneer that goes on our images
to make them more artistic for Instagram
which is of course how the apps start
even got the popular no filter
I loved the multiple interpretations of
the title I love that that no filter is
is the the phrase that people use when a
photo is too beautiful to be edited or
you know already showing something
perfect in the world
no filter it also speaks to the fact
that the default on Instagram is very
cultivated curated edited images that
people have to say no filter when
they're putting out
something that is raw true and real and
I also thought that it was important to
tell the unvarnished story of Instagram
that for my years of reporting we have
I've constantly heard about how they are
just living harmoniously within Facebook
as a company within a company how
they've really used Facebook's tools to
grow and but basically is that Decker
Berg was like a board member to
Instagram as opposed to a boss and of
course that wasn't true and so I wanted
to tell the story with no filter so
multiple interpretations of the title in
the cover here but um that's sort of how
I was thinking about it and um took a
while to convince the publisher because
you don't usually apparently you don't
usually start book titles with the word
know mmm oh that's very interesting I
have Nobel Prize which has no in my book
but yes that's right that could be seen
as a you know maybe poor marketing well
in honor of the gradient that cetera
here's a picture of the gradient that we
posted an immigrant Instagram for the
Simons Observatory which has the same
color palette my shirt you know wore
this in your honor and the roughly
hewing to the color choice that you use
I want to talk about this quote when you
when you read this quote in the New York
Times they called nofilter a sequel to
the social network how did that make you
feel how did you react to that I could
imagine in a few different ways it could
go well so I think that so there is some
positive aspects of that because the
social network was the first the first
movie that really introduced the public
to Mark Zuckerberg and helped people
sort of understand him as part of our
popular zeitgeist and it was of course a
caricature inversion a Hollywood aside
version of him but that helps people
understand the beginning is of the power
of this company in this this dominating
force but the other aspect of it of
course is that I you you've read the
book so you know I didn't want to just
tell a business story and I think social
network the social network movie and the
book that it's based on are very much
about the the boardroom drama the back
the legal issues that come across when
building Facebook when I wanted to when
I wrote this Instagram book I wanted to
interweave this corporate story and that
that corporate internal drama with the
story of how the product impacts us day
in and day out with how the many did
small decisions that people make within
the company and their of course their
personalities and their egos and their
motivations how those things affect our
human behavior and like drawing a line
between the two
so I think that that the social network
takes it one step but I want a step
further and try to explain not just like
what do we care about this in terms of
good and evil in terms of domination but
what do we care about this in terms of
its effect on us mmm
yeah and I think it is affecting it is
having you know if you had said a few
years ago oh snap chat will be so
important for disseminating even
scientific information I'm showing a
video that we posted this is taken by
our intrepid director Deborah Kellner
who's a French filmmaker who's making a
documentary about the Simons Observatory
is a time-lapse shot shot from the
Atacama Desert and she's on Instagram so
hopefully she'll tag this and and if I
had said well you know heard snapchat
would make this big impact I would have
been really dubious because you know
physically the technologies are so
radically different and yet you know
they're often spoken about in the same
in the same breath and I started to
think about what has been the impact of
this like how has it affected just my
you know little fiefdom of astronomy and
the only subject that I know
particularly well and I looked up how
many pictures has NASA posted on
Instagram and it's it's you know how
many followers does NASA and it's in the
millions hundreds of thousands and
millions of likes and shares every day
and it's it's perhaps the most effective
this and maybe Twitter arguably because
NASA is very active on Twitter and the
individual players at NASA friend of
mine or a colleague of mine from San
Diego
Jessica Muir shy interviewed her on the
space station and she was taking
pictures of you know of the earth
throughout her six months in space doing
spacewalk
and it's had this tremendous influence I
don't think that that other competitors
say like tick tock or or snapchat really
have this influence and before we get
into the technology I just wanna take
one step back to what you said about you
know the drama and the founders I was
listening to to a podcast this morning
and the they were discussing a
biographer a biography of one of the
presidents maybe and this biographer
said well you have to either love your
subject or hate your subject and you
know to be to do a good job and I felt
like you know Kevin Krieger our Kevin
Systrom and my Krieger not really like
as hateable as I'm not saying hateable I
mean I don't have anything but he's
portrayed in that movie as villainous
you know kind of venal conniving guy
like cuts out his friends and just wants
to meet girls and and he doesn't come
across great I don't say that
intentionally it's just he didn't he
didn't give you access right and
Zuckerberg sort of denied access to your
interviews in the book yeah he gave me
one quote yeah and you go through that
in the book and I'm just like he doesn't
even you know make an attempt this dear
the story and it's like if it's true I
was thinking just in terms of
financially like it's an option he could
have had if he could have steered the
message differently on the social
network book he probably you know would
have taken that opportunity nowadays to
change it rather than just suing them or
whatever he did back then but here he is
with an opportunity to talk to a you
know a bright young writer and he just
like blows you off so I think he's much
more villainous and again I have nothing
against them I've never met him
he's the great supporter of a lot of
charities and stuff that I value very
highly but what do you make about that
that the two founders of Instagram come
on very very likeable I wouldn't say
that they're like really lovable like
you don't feel super passionate about
them so how do you react to that quote
you didn't write it it's not a biography
by any means it's an insider's glimpse
into the making of this you know this
product that's changed the world but how
did you approach those two those two
characters I mean did you come fine to
you know feel for them did you feel for
their struggles or what was your
impression I think that the most
important thing to understand is that
in one of these stories is human like
Zuckerberg has his way of viewing the
world Kevin Systrom has his way of
viewing the world and in the contrast
between the two of them you can
understand them both better and Jack
Dorsey is also a character kids the CEO
of Twitter he's also a character in the
early part of my book and you understand
you know his emotion tied up and why he
invested in Instagram and so much of
what happens in Silicon Valley can be
can be boiled down to those human urges
despite the fact that we think of them
as hackers we think of them as as
cold-hearted direct minded people there
is a lot of of pride wrapped on it
wrapped up in everything that they do in
devotion to the idea of success and
Zuckerberg I think just has a very
black-and-white definition for what
success looks like success looks like
growth it looks like getting bigger it
looks like reaching more people and he
very much has this utilitarian attitude
about it where the ends justified mean
if you add more people to Facebook sure
they might they might sell illegal drugs
they might post about terrorism
organizations they might have they might
build anti-vaxxer communities they might
do all these things but he thinks that
the ends of it the the networked
community this globally connected world
that he wants to create justify the
means
and that's one reason why he has been
consolidating power and making sure that
people don't really question that future
and has been so steadfast about deciding
that his way of doing things is the
right way because he's been proven right
in the past and so I think that that
when you look at it that way he's not so
much a villain as he is as he is trying
to repeat his past successes by being
very unable to to listen to his critics
in a way that like anything that his
critics say does not discount the fact
that Facebook is getting bigger more
people are using it and I think his
biggest flaw so far is that he thinks
that the more people using the product
the more
good it is for them because why would
they use it if it wasn't good for them
right I think you either said this in an
interview or in the book you know like
when Bill Gates said you know when he
dies he wants it to be he's the richest
man who ever lived and you said
something like you know when Steve Jobs
died it would you know he created Apple
and kind of the I kept I couldn't avoid
seeing the parallels between you know
unfortunately it's always these stories
of men and Silicon Valley and you know
obviously you bring in other characters
and they're incredibly important in the
book but these huge egos and how much of
their identities are wrapped into not
only the products that they create but
attributes of the product that comes to
shine in this book in that as you say
you know Chuck is focused on the growth
of the not be aesthetic not the not the
technical details of it but how do we
monetize how do we grow it that's that's
not the way that he keeps score and you
make this point very clearly that you
know people I came in and and Mike to
some extent you know come off as more
more obsessed with the craft of it and
and what I found so fascinating is the
parallels between you know these great
you know titans of attack and and how it
seems to just play out like in every
generation like there's this famous
saying attributed to Max Planck that
science progresses one funeral at a time
and I feel like you know it's like
technology is also kind of progressing
like that that maybe maybe tell me if
you agree but it seems like you know the
aesthetic side is being picked up by the
instagrams and the Kevin systems of the
world whereas that you know the
Microsoft Gates Ian obsession with
domination and and so forth is being
taken up the mantle is being taken up by
Zuckerberg and Facebook I think that's
true but I think that that I would take
it a step further and say like you
cannot or at least Zuckerberg things
that you cannot fully scale quickly
scale a product if you care about the
little details and the little touches
and the tone of something and the craft
of something at a certain point when you
get to a billion users or you know even
hundreds of million you start to lose
control of what the community does and
it gets boiled down to its most bare
incentives which is get more followers
get more likes get more comments like
the people
using the platform start to define what
it's for as opposed to the company and I
think that that heaven and my stay where
they were very focused on promoting the
good of Instagram and of showing off how
wonderful was that all these communities
were connecting and how simple and
perfect the community could be meanwhile
the people who use Instagram of some of
us as humans have a more Zuckerberg ian
mentality where we're all about growth
and now that we can see the measurements
at the top of our feed we can see the
analytics we know what kind of content
does better on Instagram and we can
adjust our behavior just like Zuckerberg
adjusts the Facebook product we can
tweak tweak tweak until we know our best
photo angles until we know what works
and and I think that that was really
interesting to me to see to see these
Facebook tactics be taught to us at
large as a society while Instagram is
trying to teach us how to be creative
and cultured it's kind of interesting to
see that ultimately what wins out is
this drive to to grow and appear
successful and to measure that success
in a way that is that is more numbers
base as opposed to subjective mmm so
another thing that really spoke to me in
the book is you portray the competition
that endured even after the acquisition
the famous acquisition which created so
many headlines the first kind of you
know app unicorn 13 employees and you go
through and it's really it's it's
amazing because it must have been a
challenge for you to like make something
suspenseful when a lot of people already
know the story how famous it is I mean
talk about the challenge of you know
portraying a story and making it so
exciting when you know the outcome is
sort of spoiled the spoiler alert was
out there years before the bug as
journalists were always focused on
answering the question of what's
happened and what what'll happen next
and trying to break the news and get the
details and then we have to move on to
the next story and with a book what you
can do is you can go back to all those
people that were involved in the story
at the time and say how did this happen
why did this happen who argued for what
and what did they say
who
the room and what could have gone
differently and that was really
fascinating to me because but before I
went into this project I didn't realize
that the Instagram employees didn't make
much and for the most part didn't make
money off of the deal the news stories
at the time said that you know Instagram
is now worth 77 million per employee and
I just assumed that they were all
millionaires and in fact that's not how
it worked out and and there were other
asset like I had no idea how heartbroken
Jack Dorsey was that Instagram sold to
Facebook instead of to Twitter so II in
peeling back those layers you understand
the human side of the story and all of
the factors that went into the part of
history that so it's kind of like a
decoding project where you figure out
like this is this is just these are just
people I mean there's not there's not
any sort of rules to how these things
are done it was the first billion dollar
acquisition ever and they kind of just
invented history as they went along and
the way that they the way that they
decided to do things it was not
inevitable it's not like this could have
just happened with any photo app and it
could have been we could have lived in a
completely different world depending on
the different decisions that they made
yeah I was not aware of this
you know pre-existing app called bourbon
and you go into that fascinating history
and yeah the counterfactual of you know
how this could have played out I I first
you know just because it's my
prerogative it's my podcast I want to
ask you don't you think it would have
been more natural for Twitter to buy
Instagram isn't it sort of more Twitter
like than Facebook like I mean now it's
like Instagram by facebook on the bond
the app it's just like you go into that
and it's just like coming just just kind
of jars me what do you think what was
more natural even even with the benefit
of hindsight is Twitter really or is
Facebook really the right home for it
well I think Twitter is more natural and
that's also why Instagram didn't want to
go there because it was too similar when
the Twitter board looked at Instagram
they saw wow this is the perfect way to
post photos on Twitter this is a
parallel network that's pretty
the same thing there it still has as a
follower model so the biggest if one of
the biggest differences between Facebook
and Instagram is Instagram you can
follow people who don't follow me back
and that's the same as on as on Twitter
there's anonymity on Instagram you could
have multiple accounts on Instagram the
way you can on Twitter whereas Facebook
is all centered around real identity so
when they when they would if they had
gone to Twitter Twitter was saying Oh
Kevin Systrom could be head of product
at Twitter and also run Instagram like
there wasn't as much clarity of like the
division whereas when Zuckerberg went to
Kevin Systrom he said you can be CEO you
can be independent within Facebook and
we won't touch you yeah and that's
exactly segues into what I want to talk
about next it struck me is so odd the
scenes that you portray in the book are
really kind of unsettling in a sense and
I tried to make an analogy because I'm
you know just a simple-minded
astrophysicist but but I was thinking
when we hire a professor like a young
professor from say someone who's a
postdoctoral fellow so after graduate
school you probably know you know you
might you might become what's called a
postdoctoral fellow or scholar where
it's kind of a purgatory in between
being a graduate student where you work
for somebody else's projects and when
you're starting to come up with your own
ideas as an independent scientist and so
if we're trying to hire somebody we
don't like hire you know prior professor
and then and then say to her now you're
like you know you're a threat like now
what you do is directly competing with
what we do or I do I hired I was on the
hiring committee no it's not like that
at all or when you get married you sound
like wait let's say you worked the same
company now you're like a threat to my
promote like it just seems it seems it
you know for lack of a better word it's
an it sounded a little bit like you know
if you if you look at Facebook as a
corporation as an individual that they
they have no zero emotional intelligence
it just struck me as so odd to set it up
and yeah they had a carve out a CEO and
make you know that was one way of
handling it but what what what affected
you about the way that they were
perceived as almost like this enemy cell
within within Facebook or computing your
friends close keep your enemies closer
right
I mean I think Facebook needed to buy
Instagram in order to make sure that it
didn't get didn't take away from
Facebook and one of the things that
really shocked me and reporting this out
is just a few weeks or within a few
weeks of Instagram joining Facebook you
know they go through their orientation
they they get set up in their office and
the the only guy working on analytics at
Instagram goes to meet with the growth
team at Facebook and the growth team
says hey listen welcome to the team
but we're not going to help you guys
until we find out if you are going to be
at all of a threat to the amount of
pictures that people post on Facebook so
already they were willing to sacrifice
the potential of this asset that they
paid a billion dollars for which was
unheard of but they knew that the most
important part of the acquisition was
taking Instagram off the field from
there once they figured out that it
wasn't a direct threat to Facebook then
they could build it up and have sort of
a Facebook 2.0 within the company but
that was foreshadowing for what happened
later of course when when Instagram gets
to the sides where Zuckerberg does feel
like it's a threat to Facebook and and
you're right I feel like that's that's
not a that's not the way that that if
you are a consumer of these products you
think it would go and when I went into
writing this book when I put out my
proposal to do it I thought maybe I
would be writing about Facebook's
feature I would be writing about you
know this this thing that at a time that
Facebook is under scrutiny it's been why
the critiques people are leaving in and
you know saying that they have a bad
experience there and they're escaping to
Instagram and maybe Instagram is like
the second wave of Facebook's dominance
in the world and when I started digging
into it and realizing that faces did not
want that to be the future of the
company I thought that that was really
interesting it just speaks to to what
you've been talking about ego and about
Zuckerberg wanting to to achieve
dominance in the in the way that he sees
fit mm-hmm yeah it's almost like a Greek
you know tragic and
fatal flaw but you know you can't argue
with success and as you mentioned the
book you know they're kind of different
ethos that they would staple you know on
post-it notes or paint on the wall you
know versus the way that Kevin and Mike
were more kind of open even with like
you just got like a glass garage door
you know partitioning their oven it's
sort of you know versus the walled
garden and I think it was in your
interview with Kara Swisher a couple of
a month ago now and the book first came
out in April and you're talking about
you know just the level of kind of
almost dread that one feels when one
logs on to Facebook and like am I gonna
see some stupid red dot you know versus
Instagram which is kind of like
delightful and and provocative but but
one and it kind of draws you in and
you're not gonna be just like you're the
product as soon as you get on there but
I want to talk about how it became so
viral in your opinion and really what it
means to you now which is really
catching around thought like I
personally don't really care what some
Kardashian wants to you know promote if
you know her lipstick or whatever what
is sort of the the the responsible for
more of the success is it the everyday
people you know put you talk about these
accounts that went viral overnight from
like a dog you know it's just like so
cute and like I'm listening to your book
and I'm like you know typing and so I
gotta follow this account you know like
everybody follows the Instagram you know
main account but what about the the you
know kind of the dichotomy of of
usership you know between the ultra
famous influencers you know who clearly
make you feel like the product versus
the individuals you know the the riff
raff like me who want feel like oh we're
using it as a product ourselves I think
that what what it's done is it's made
everyone a potential famous person that
if you just tried at Instagram and
decided to come up with a brand or
decided to come up with you know whether
it's your photography or your baking or
whatever it might be that anyone has the
potential to become an influencer or
even has a potential to be seen by other
people in society as interesting and
worthy of attention and so I think that
the the big effect of Instagram is that
it's become this societal benchmarking
tool it's like something where you know
if you walk down the street and you see
on someone's forehead how much money
they make that's kind of what Instagram
is you would look at someone's follower
kids count and say oh this is how
culturally influential this person is
just crazy to have in our society like
like even with the verified you know the
verified yeah we look marks we've never
really had something like that before um
and I think that that it that can be it
can provide great opportunity for people
so you know like the owner of a dog that
you talked about are certain fitness
instructors who got into the millions
and following without going through the
normal gatekeepers so if you want to be
an actor if you want to be a comedian if
you want to be a singer you kind of just
start on Instagram and get to your dream
a different way on the flip side it
creates this tremendous amount of
personal stress for people who are using
it and caring about those metrics and
and even forcing people you know they
feel like they need to do this in order
to be successful and so they'll cheat
and they'll buy followers of a by
comments or they'll adjust their
appearance through facetune or plastic
surgery and I think that it's that sort
of harmful effect that we need to
understand about Instagram so that we
can kind of give ourselves a break we're
all the pressure we feel right yeah and
I think that that is you know that's
endemic to all these you know channels
it's sort of like you know it's ironic
in this age of the coronavirus that we
want to be viral and be famous and I
just I remember watching this there's a
documentary with Bill Murray in it and
he said something to the effect of like
you don't want to be famous like try
being rich because you know rich gives
you most of the perks of that being
famous could even potentially give you
without a lot of the risks and downsides
stock and having Big Brother and AI and
content reviewing
hacked a lot of good hack on Instagram
right and their most intimate things go
out yeah to me I'm always thinking of
this quote by George Orwell in Animal
Farm when he talks about Benjamin the
donkey and I think the pig talks to
Benjamin says oh you have such a nice
tail and the donkey says you know the
flaw of the the God the Lord gave me a
tail to swat away the Flies but I'd
rather not have the Flies and not need
the tail and I can I can sort of
identify luckily with you know a
thousand followers I don't have to worry
about that I want to talk about
technology and we chatted before the
show and I think you have the same
publicist or the same folks at is a
Simon & Schuster yeah as Peter Diamandis
who was on the show a couple of weeks
ago now and I talked to you about what
Peter and his author co-author Stephen
Cutler described as the as the six DS of
Technology of exponential organizations
and according to Peter those are
digitization deception disruption D
monetization dematerialization and
democratization it talks about different
fates in fact he uses the different
fates between Kodak and Instagram to
illustrate how these different these
different technologies really affected
the world I mean Kodak had essentially
the first patent on the CCD camera on
the you know instant you know digital
camera and they they squandered it and
they wanted to remain entrenched with
their technology of you know physically
printing out photographic film whereas
you know Instagram could scale up and I
codex a shadow of its former self but
I'm wondering about the technology you
know in his language these these
different forces the exponential forces
that are coming over time there is a
limit to exponential growth we can't you
know we don't live on a planet with
infinite resources we don't have
infinite numbers of people although you
know sometimes it would seem that way
but how does Instagram and even Facebook
counteract these exponential realities
you know growth with the reality of
living in a finite resource planet
well isn't it crazy that the biggest
barrier to growth for Facebook is not
competition but the limited number of
people who use the internet in the world
you know I mean that is just
mind-blowing right like they have they
have about 3 billion users of all
Facebook properties now so that's
Facebook whatsapp messenger and
Instagram and there are about 7 billion
people in the world they already have
the majority of the world's Internet
connection population using Facebook the
rest are in China outside of China
properties are still blocked and so the
way that Zuckerberg is trying to build
upon that I mean he's running out of
ways to grow infinitely but he is trying
to increase the number of connections
between people so one of the things that
really frustrated the founders of
Instagram is docker Berg decided that he
wanted to build a mega network that he
wanted to connect the networks of
Facebook Instagram whatsapp and
messenger and call it one family of apps
and have it all operate under Facebook
so that people could message each other
whether they were on whatsapp or a
messenger or Facebook gem it could
message each other on other platforms
and therefore increase their overall
network he's also trying to get people
to use Facebook groups so that they can
befriend people who they haven't met in
real life because if you're in a
Facebook group and you're talking with a
lot of people about a certain topic you
can befriend each other without ever
having met and so by growing these
networks to be larger he increases the
potential for the freshness of the
platform and also the amount of value we
get from each other but there's a
there's a flipside to that which is when
our networks are bigger we share less
intimately and we don't feel as
comfortable being our full selves and so
I think that that although you can look
at it in a very utilitarian grow grow
grow mentality like Zuckerberg does you
also have to think about the cost of
that growth or the experience of the
user
yeah that's certainly you know threat
and I would say is you know kind of over
engineering the
and you know it's clear that Facebook
has enough talent that they could have
identical replicas of Instagram in fact
you describe their very efforts to do
that and their challenge faced by
snapchat I wonder just personally again
my prerogative you don't have to answer
any question but do you use snapchat and
if so how much because I find it not
appealing maybe I'm you know pre boomer
you know okay Gen X guy but but
nevertheless I I don't find I don't see
the appeal of it can you can you speak
about that is it a threat to Instagram
Facebook i I think that it is more in
the messaging category and more for
young people I think I think snapchat is
intentionally difficult for older people
to use it is you swipe upside down left
and right and it's not very intuitive
for people who started on computers but
I do think that for the younger
generation because they have that
smaller Network they can be more
intimate and snapchat is actually bigger
now than Twitter by market cap or by
user base by user base oh wow it's also
I think market cap is bigger too I think
I think you're correct for that and and
the other big threat is tic-tock
tic-tock has become a major escape for
young people during coronavirus because
it is full of happy videos yeah things
showing pets doing silly things and
dance moves and cooking it's it's just a
different kind of experience as opposed
to what you get from from Instagram
Twitter where you have to create the
content yeah yeah I am yeah just to give
my my millennial credentials I am on tic
TOCs oh yeah but I am NOT I'm trying to
do you know a one-minute general
relativity quantum electrodynamics
lectures and you be mine you double my
follower base so I hope but I look at it
and I think about you know you write
about the the really the early history
and even the the tie-ins with Jack
Dorsey and Twitter and I started
thinking about it in terms of and you
must have had this cross your mind to
you know that both the you know
the emergence of Twitter and Instagram
came about after the you know 2008-2009
financial collapse and really the
popularization of Facebook really that's
where the knee that's where they you
know the the take-off point in a ramp of
exponential 'ti took place for Facebook
but I think will be that for this Cova
generation do you think it's something
like tick-tock or something like
snapchat or is it something that
nobody's thinking about and in the words
of you know Facebook you know founder
Mark Zuckerberg you know if we don't
make the thing that kills Facebook
somebody else will if we don't make the
thing that kills Twitter what what is
next what's going to come out of this Co
that you know pandemic that could rival
something like an Instagram I think it's
very possible that something will come
out right now but whenever there is a
big disruption and the way people live
there is always opportunity to fill the
needs of everyone and I haven't seen it
yet I mean tick tock is certainly I
would say tick tock has already emerged
snapchat is already emerged I wouldn't
consider them startups yeah what I think
that we will see is something that helps
people feel entertained connected but so
far the big bets that have launched have
not fulfilled the needs like kwibi and
with this big video platform that just
launched a seven-second or sorry six
minute videos for people during
quarantine they thought that people
would really want to watch it because
they'd watch it during the daytime as
opposed to evening when they watched
Netflix hasn't caught on so so I think
that people are going to keep trying
things keep trying new things and this
is the time to attempt it because with
constraint there is creativity that's
one of the things that the Instagram
founders learned early on they made
square photos and they thought with the
square photos it will be just like
Twitter's 180 character limit with
constraint people become creative and
what bigger constraints on the way we
live then coronavirus yeah so past
episode last year I talked with Julian
Guthrie about her book alpha girls which
is a wonderful
and I'm recommended that she get in
touch with you about fat female founders
in the Silicon Valley ecosystem of the
you know 70s 80s 90s and one thing that
really comes out of her writing and that
really kind of eerily echoed in your
writing is that this this is really a
book about leadership in a stealthy way
because I think you're you go through
and kind of I almost feel a little bit
like Kevin is sort of a Kevin Systrom is
a is a little bit pathetic not like in a
negative but just that you have sympathy
for him because you know he tried to be
a like he studied how to be a leader and
he's trying to be a leader you know yeah
and he took courses and you you talk
about you know how he has these
management coach with the big personal
improver yeah and you kind of see this
you know it's parodied in Silicon Valley
the TV show it's just like having your
gurus or whatever and any any talk about
you know that he took that and I feel it
was bad for him because in the end you
know he started I mean it's hard to feel
too bad cuz he's got a billion dollars
but you know he's also at 36 37 he just
had a kid where does he go from here and
well let me take a step back what
leadership lessons can you take from him
because we often have situations where
we'll have an experiment and it's an
arch competitor of ours but we obviously
could be much better if we merge and
achieve the synergy do you think
ultimately like he fell sort of on the
sword to do what's best for the child or
the creative you know the thing that he
created or do you think he just had a
failure to see that this huge Python was
gonna swallow him like a like a Pangolin
nom I shouldn't say but yeah do you feel
like yeah that he was just like kind of
a unaware and and almost you know kind
of got what he deserved because he
didn't game out in his and his mind all
the things that it could be taken away
from him I think he was a very strategic
person in terms of his diplomacy
internally at Facebook in the fact that
he didn't get it right really bothered
him and he found that he had Zuckerberg
figured out he thought as long as I keep
growing Instagram as long as I ramped up
the revenue and I keep users coming back
then
Zuckerberg I will also if I helped crush
the competition then Zuckerberg will
respect me and reward
that effort with more independence with
more resources and in fact the opposite
turned out to be true that when he when
he did crush the competition and build
up Instagram until its growth was
accelerating in 2016
Zuckerberg then looked at him and saw
threat so I think that he miscalculated
what was going to happen if he succeeded
the way Zuckerberg wanted him to and I
think that sometimes when we when we do
we think we should do it in order to win
it doesn't always result in the the way
that we think is most logical because we
all have our own biases around what we
think like leaders I guess I'd say Kevin
Systrom was on bloomer television a
couple weeks ago my colleagues airfryer
just came out with a book about
Instagram called no filter and her
conclusion is that Facebook is under
investing in Instagram specific problems
I wonder if you agree with that and if
so does that concern you about whether
instagrams growth will falter I mean
Instagram for investors is one of the
great hopes
Facebook's overall growth should they be
concerned that Instagram won't grow like
it did well I haven't read the book I
did live the history right and I saw
places where I think we invested
appropriately and places where I wish we
had invested more but the truth of it is
that we grew the platform to over a
billion people and you don't do that
with nobody on you don't do that with no
resources that being said you know I I
don't know what's happening on the
inside and for me to speculate what
investments have or have not been made
is very difficult to do from the outside
but you know if I were in charge of
Facebook and I saw something like
Instagram I'd obviously invest a lot in
it to make sure that you know it becomes
another pillar of the many products that
we have as a company and I think that's
just the logical argument to make and
the logical thing to do and I think
marks a very logical person and and
hopefully he's following that well he
thinks in that moment that he's
appealing to Zuckerberg
but really the thing that ultimately
helped Zuckerberg make the decisions
that he made was was more about ego more
about how he perceives them success
and so I think that that painting
Zuckerberg is too one-dimensional as to
focus on the numbers discounts the fact
that he was also human he's also trying
to to win as a leader too so so I think
that that at a certain point at the top
of a company it was lonely Roland
there's only room for like one guy who
feels that they have the perfect vision
and it was only a matter of time before
they clash yeah yeah you see this a lot
in one of the people and blurbed your
book Ashley Vance in the book about Elon
Musk and you've seen this obviously and
they see jobs movies and and the books
written about him and and now you're
seeing and the social network and now
you're seeing a no filter your wonderful
new book I want to conclude or start to
wrap up a little bit with thinking about
technology and and how technology will
influence the future of things like
Instagram snapchat Facebook etc and
that's this notion of 5g connectivity
that's very important here in San Diego
because we have Qualcomm here and all
Cummins one of the pioneers has some of
the first patents in the 5g space so
again Steven Kotler and Peter Diamandis
spoke about well this is gonna be one of
the most you know most transformative
technologies that will define the future
will be the advent of 5g and I'm
wondering and that's primarily because
of the reduction in latency between
different effects taking place on the
internet and queuing and more targeting
of individual handsets do you see the
technology of things like 5g or anything
else being used to kind of augment
Instagram in the way that say snap
glasses or whatever they're called
snapchat had their snap are still does
maybe Google had their their Google
glasses oculus was acquired by Facebook
you know thanks to Instagram for three
times as much money as you talked about
in the book is there a technology that
will augment Instagram or will it get
left behind potentially in this 5g
revolution
I think that there are a lot of use
cases that you can imagine right now
like what if you could watch a live
musical act and everyone in the musical
act was performing from their own home
but they could all hear each other and
harmonize like that would be really cool
so I think that there are ways that
either you can do more real time based
recognition technology Facebook there's
a the data aspect of it right like
Facebook will be able to quickly
understand what's happening in our
videos and be able to target us ads in
real time based on what we say and do
which is kind of a scary thought but
it's certainly more possible in a 5g
world we can lean a lot harder into
video as users and I think we're already
seeing that happen during coronavirus
and we're doing this call / zoom I think
that kind of thing will become a lot
more prevalent I think that the we might
skip over VR as the technology that that
will be life changing and maybe switch
to AR we're already seeing that become
quite useful on snap in these funny face
filters but there would be many more
applications for it down the line like
for telemedicine so so I think that that
there are certainly possibilities with
Instagram and I've seen I've seen a lot
happened on Instagram with regards to
live video that I didn't expect and I
think that we will be able to see a lot
a lot richer content yeah I had a
nightmare after finishing the book on
Friday and realizing well what happens
in the first person you know does their
live Instagram feed of their you know
plastic surgery to make themselves look
better for instance just this would you
have to tell me that Sarah I wish I
could unlearn that I want to finish up
because we only have a couple minutes
left I want to finish up with the kind
of where are they now and where do they
go from here so you know being kicked
out of a you know company you know it's
a hard thing a founder of something
especially at a young age now you know
he has a billion reason you know the
better part of a billion reasons that
might have swage some of the pain of the
blow of being let loose yeah what is he
doing now I mean you usually hear these
politicians retire even when they're
young because they want to spend more
time with their family I mean is that I
mean that's Noble it is but but what is
uh what are they up to now these two
these two founders well microgrid just
had his first kid Kevin Systrom had his
second he learned to fly a plane that's
right yes yes generally the two of them
say that they are trying to figure out
what they want they're sort of
decompressing after this six year
high-intensity period and trying a lot
of things a lot of experimental things
and right now they're doing a very
interesting project called RT live what
it looks at is the reproduction rate of
coronavirus in certain states the
likelihood that a person who is infected
will infect other people and so they so
remember how I told you in the beginning
of our conversation that for Instagram
the most important thing was that they
solved the issue as simply as possible
that they focus just on photos well now
they're doing that with coronavirus
they're trying to give a website where
you look at it and you see a very simple
answer about whether a certain state is
safe or not
so that's kind of interesting but I
don't think that's the next company I
think that they are going to they're
going to continue to noodle on what
they'll do next but I do think that
they're likely to do it together huh
well that's good to hear and that they
maintain the connection to one another a
lot of times it kind of drives people
apart you know even families you win the
lottery and then that's the end of the
family as you descend into addiction
like that resignation okay so we're
going to finish up with five questions
that I call the final five on the into
the impossible podcast we're here sarah
fryer is amazing new book no filter is
really captured in a way not just the
technology the rivalries etc but the
real personalities is I felt like you're
a detective
really unraveling some of these there
intimate personal details of the story
that would would have remained hidden
without without your intrepid journalism
so I thank you so much for bringing
these to life so the final questions
some of them are revolve around books
and some of them are just to learn so
our listeners can learn from high
achievers top performers like you I'll
start with two that are about books so
Carl Sagan I had on his daughter and and
reans daughter Sascha Segan a couple
weeks ago and he spoke about books as
magic as sort of a device a technology
that can insert somebody's words and
nowadays he wrote that before you know
audiobooks are really popular now you
can actually hear the voice I believe
you you narrated the introduction right
no Philip yeah and that was not really
lovely and the other other narrator she
did a wonderful job too but I want to
ask about the future in this book and
and kind of what what you see is the
long-term influence of the book I
usually ask people would you rather have
if you're an author would you rather
have a hundred people reading your book
a year from now or you know or want one
person reading it a hundred years from
now so I'm gonna ask you that even
though it's about a technology it's also
about you know eternal stories of
rivalry of competition of struggling and
documenting a particular phase in the
world so which would you rather have ser
a hundred readers tomorrow or one reader
a hundred years from them Wow well I
would hope that if a hundred people read
it tomorrow that somebody will find it a
hundred years from now but I think I
think that is if it's already feeling
like a story about a moment in time that
that people will will look at this as
the the 20 times in Silicon Valley and I
think that the New York Times said that
in their review especially now that our
lives have changed so much from the time
of this book's publication you can look
back at it and and see it as a slice of
this this dramatic increase individual
communication this force that affected
society and so it would be very fun if
somebody read it a hundred years ago and
as far as those readers you know either
now or in the future hopefully you'll
have plenty of both hmm what would be
your preference for people to read
would it be people that are kind of
either skeptical that Instagram is
really you know kind of an important
enough contribution to our culture you
know people that are that really view it
and to cry it's it's negative influences
on society as we touched upon or people
that really are just super curious about
you know how did it grow and and so
forth so kind of haters or fans what's
your ideal target audience if you had to
choose one my ideal reader is somebody
who who uses who has known about
instagrams impact on their life and who
was maybe change their behavior to
adhere to Instagram but doesn't know why
and they read the book and then they
understand the behind the scenes why we
do what we do on Instagram how we got
there that you know that they can then
take a step back and think okay now I
know why I act this way or why my
friends are acting this way and I can I
can disentangle myself from this
pressure and then understand how to use
it in a more healthy manner Thanks okay
next question revolves again sort of on
past advice if you will or stuff in the
past so the title of this podcast is one
of the into the impossible podcast is
one of arthur c-- clark s-- famous laws
his first law is that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
you may have heard that and the second
law is that is that the only way to find
out what is possible is to venture
beyond a little bit into the impossible
so looking back at your career and where
you've been is there something that
seemed very difficult when you were you
know a younger person and starting off
that having done things such as writing
this book which is a huge accomplishment
you know you would give advice to your
younger self in your 20s or what have
you that you've been able to see by
going a little bit into the impossible
you can achieve such great things so the
advice my under self yeah basically well
I think I would say that when you're
starting out your career you start out
as a people pleaser you start out try
to be helpful trying to be curious
trying to fit in where there are gaps
and it took me a long time to understand
that my opinions and my way of seeing
the world was valuable and so if I could
go back and talk to my younger self I
would want her to understand that it was
that it's okay to say what you what you
want to know and to drive your own
covers and to drive your own questioning
and not wait for someone to ask you to
do it and because once I got to that
point in my career once I realized that
what I was doing was of value to people
then I started to get the confidence to
dig into projects like this oh very good
and the next question that I ask all my
author guests is who's gonna play Kevin
Systrom and the movie treatment that I'm
sure you're working on oh my gosh I'm so
bad at actors one person told me Keanu
Reeves but you might be a little old but
it's shorter it's so good one so giddy
and still might not be tall enough
although you would need to be someone
someone tall you're right yeah and the
thing I was thinking about that and the
guys who played the wincle of it-- wins
that guy I think that'd be a good I was
actually surprised that they if they
really want to get back at suck the best
thing that they should have done is
bought Instagram you know when it was
younger and smaller and they could have
taken just directly beneath a went into
Bitcoin exactly right maybe that'll that
was a better decision who knows and then
last question is just where can people
find you what are you working on now and
yeah a little bit of the plug zone so
let us know what you're working on next
is it another book or other projects
that you're involved with and then how
people can find you so I am a reporter
at Bloomberg and Businessweek and I'm
still digging into all these same
stories trying to I just report it on
Facebook sack we just acquisition of
Jaffe
I've been reporting on the fact of
coronavirus on tech workers all sorts of
things in that vein you can follow me on
twitter at sarah fryer or instagram also
at sarah fryer that's where i tend to
post the most of my stories and
I always the one thing I'll say is I
always look forward to hearing from
users of these products I think that you
can't fully tell the business story
unless you understand the consumer story
and so I always appreciate people
reaching out to me and telling me how
these platforms have affected their
lives where they're running into trouble
and where they see opportunity that's
wonderful Sarah thank you so much for
sharing your ideas and your wonderful
book congratulations on this huge
accomplishment and we look forward to
seeing all the interesting things you
come up with going forward thank you
Sarah thank you so much for having me
pick her any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
Twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
YouTube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c-- clark center for human imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco